[Applaudissements]
besoin de série alors moi j'ai été très
ému aussi comme tout le monde par ses
adieux elle était très solide voilà très
digne on l'a tous dit mais sûreté puis
elle s'est fait virer peut-être de
manière inélégante mais ça arrive à des
tas de gens qui ne prendront pas les
milliers d'euros qu'il va prendre après
alors quand même essayer d'arrêter un
petit peu le déballage de bons
sentiments surtout qu'elle s'en est pris
plein la tronche par certains certaines
de ces personnalités certains
journalistes qui étaient très contents
lui en met plein la tronche toute
l'année en disant que justement elle
était sur la fin que claire chazal
n'était plus sur la fin et alors
maintenant ça y est et on sort les
petits coeurs et le ballon et la fiesta
mais la pauvre clair on va dire années
patrick sébastien a produit junior
alors oui poésie permanent de ce musée
voulu revoir très vite
oui parce qu'elle sur quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parisien
si on veut voir le côté positif le verre
à moitié plein on peut dire aussi que
tf1 devant nos services on l'a débarqué
à un moment elle est encore en tête des
audiences si elle avait était encore aux
commandes le jodo house serait passé
devant on là pour le coup tout le monde
est tombé dessus la chasse est d'accord
va venir après sur ce qu'elle va faire
parce que vous avez des impôts tout ce
qu'elle va faire et sur ses indemnités
je crois qu'il y ait plein coeur là où
je suis d'accord avec ce que dit jean
michel c'est quand tu dit elle la levée
que l'image de quelqu'un de vie réelle a
d'abord la compassion pour elle entre
eux outre